♪
♪.
CHARLIE: WELCOME BACK TO "THE
BIG SUNDAY SHOW" DR. FAUCI IS
BACK TALKING ABOUT THE COVID
VARIANT AND THE POSSIBILITY
WOULD BRING BACK RESTRICTIONS.
DR. FAUCI SAYS WE NEED TO BE
FLEXIBLE.
>> I DON'T SEE US GOING BACK
INTO RESTRICT RESTRICTIONS BUT
YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY.
IF WE DO SEE A SIGNIFICANT SURGE
ONE THAT MIGHT RESULT IN
INCREASED HOSPITALIZATION WE
HAVE TO BE PREPARED TO PIVOT AND
REINSTITUTE SOME OF THOSE
RESTRICTIONS.
>> SE TOUTS NEW RESTRICTIONS HE
IS ALSO TALKING ABOUT
RETIREMENT.
HE IS TELLING "FOX & FRIENDS"
WEEKEND, IT IS ABOUT TIME THAT
HE GO.
>> WELL PAST TIME WHEN HE
SHOULD'VE RETIRED.
I DON'T SEE HOW ANYBODY COULD
TAKE A LOOK AT OUR RESPONSE TO
COVID, 965,000 AMERICANS DEAD,
6 MILLION PEOPLE WORLDWIDE, THE
HUMAN TOLL OF THE ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION FROM THE WIDESPREAD
SHUTDOWNS.
WHAT WE DO DURING CHILDREN PUT
THEM IN A STATE OF FEAR IS A
TRAGEDY AND ANTHONY FAUCI LED
THE MISERABLE FAILURE TO RESPOND
AND HE SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE SPEAKER BEFORE WE
TALK ABOUT DOCTOR SACHI RIDING
OFF INTO THE SUN CHECK.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU YOU'RE VERY
WISE OBSERVER OF POLITICAL
THINGS.
IS THERE ANYBODY LEFT WHO IS
EAGER FOR NEW MANDATES OR GOING
BACK TO ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE ENDURED FOR THE PAST FEW
YEARS.
TAMMY: THERE ARE, THE NEW YORK
TIMES DID A STORY IN THE POLL,
INSTITUTED THEIR OWN POLL.
THEY FOUND A VERY LIBERAL VERSUS
THE LIBERAL MODERATES AND
CONSERVATIVES REMAINED IN FEAR.
THEY WANTED THE MANDATES MORE SO
THAN EVERY OTHER CATEGORY.
PERHAPS DR. FAUCI IS VERY
LIBERAL BUT THIS TALKS AND
SPEAKS TO THE NATURE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO THE LIBERAL BASE THE
ULTIMATE LIBERALS THE FAR LEFT,
THE PROGRESSIVES AND THIS IS HOW
THEY THINK.
THE REALITY THIS IS MORE FEAR
MONGERING HE SAYS ASSESSOR
COMING OUT OF THIS.
WE KNOW IT WAS A FAILURE WHAT HE
IMPLEMENTED.
IT'S BEEN THE ONE SUCCESS STORY
VACCINES BROUGHT TO US BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND NATURAL
IMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED.
I THINK 80% OF AMERICANS HAVE
HAD A SHOT OR DYNAMIC.
THIS IS WHY -- THIS IS NOT MARCH
OF 2020.
THIS IS A MAN WHO IS SPEAKING AS
THOUGH NOTHING IS HAPPENED IN
THE MEANTIME.
EVERYTHING IS DIFFERENT.
THE WORLD IS DIFFERENT.
NATURAL IMMUNITY, THE VACCINE,
EVERYTHING THAT WE LEARN.
WE KNOW THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
THE WORLD, EUROPE, ITALY KNOW
THAT THIS IS NOT RIGHT AND THIS
IS MORE FEAR MONGERING FROM A
MAN WHO NEEDS TO LEAVE THE
SCENE.
>> AS YOU KNOW TRUE SELF
RESPECTING LIBERALS WOULD WANT
TO LIBERAL UNDER AN
AUTHORITARIAN LIKE ANTHONY FAUCI
IN THE FIRST PLACE BUT THAT IS
FOR ANOTHER TIME.
I WANTED TO LISTEN TO THIS
COMMENT FROM DR. FAUCI TALKING
ABOUT RETIREMENT.
>> ARE WE APPROACHING THE POINT
WHERE WERE PAST THE PANDEMIC AND
WE CAN GET SOME REST?
>> I'M NOT SO SURE I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WERE OUT OF THIS
BEFORE I CONSIDER DOING ANYTHING
DIFFERENT.
WE HAVE A WAY TO GO.
CHARLIE: IS IT TIME FOR HIM TO
POSSIBLY RETIRE?
>> IT MIGHT BE IN A BE UP TO
HIM.
I THINK THAT THIS SERVES THE
LAST TWO YEARS HAVE SERVED AS A
WARNING TO ANY FUTURE HEALTHCARE
LEADER IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOU ARE NOT CAREFUL AGAINST
THE POLITICAL BACKDROP AND YOUR
DOCTOR AND YOUR TAKING ASIDE
THERE WILL BE PEOPLE WHO LISTEN
CLOSER IF THEY AGREE WITH YOUR
SIDE.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF OTHER PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY WHO FELT IGNORED
BY THE SIGN THAT THEY THOUGHT
DR. FAUCI WAS TAKING.
THAT CAN BE DANGEROUS THERE WERE
CAREERS DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT
WERE BUILT AND DESTROYED WHILE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
GLOBE DIED.
WHETHER OR NOT HE RETIRES.
I DON'T IF IT CHANGES THE GAME.
I THINK A LOT OF MISTAKES WERE
MADE AND A LOT OF LESSONS TO BE
LEARNED.
>> ABSOLUTELY I DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF FAITH ANYBODY IN GOVERNMENT
IS LEARNING THOSE LESSONS BUT IT
IS ALARMING THE DEGREE BECAUSE
THE STUFF GOT SO POLITICIZED THE
DEGREE TO WHICH THEY DESTROYED
NOT THEIR OWN CREDIBILITY BUT
THE CREDIBILITY OF THEIR
SUCCESSORS TO DEAL WITH ANOTHER
PROBLEM EXISTS.
I DON'T TINGLE EVER BELIEVE A
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRAT WHEN IT
COMES TO HEALTHCARE.
IF YOU HAD A PEDIATRICIAN THAT I
GOT IN IS MANY THINGS WRONG
TAKING CARE OF YOUR CHILD AS DRE
MAKE YOU WOULD'VE FIRED THEM TWO
YEARS AGO.
JOEY: THEY WENT FROM 15 DAYS TO
SLOW THE SPREAD TO LOCK
EVERYTHING DOWN BECAUSE YOU
CANNOT AFFORD TO CATCH THE
VIRUS.
THEY LOST ME, I'M NOT THAT
STUPID I LISTENED AND I KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
THINGS WHEN YOU SLIDE YOUR HAND
YOU LOSE ME.
IMAGINE HAVING THE HUMERUS TO
THINK IF YOU RETIRE A COUNTRY OF
330 MILLION AMERICANS ARE NOT
SMART ENOUGH TO FIGURE IT OUT
FOR THEMSELVES.
TAKE ALL THE PEOPLE THAT WORK
FOR HIM THAT MIGHT HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION AND BRILLIANT
IN THEIR OWN MIND.
THIS GUY FOR WHATEVER HIS
INTENTIONS ARE AND I WILL NOT
TRY TO DEFINE THEM.
HE HAS TO UNDERSTAND THE
COUNTRIES GOING TO MOVE ON WITH
OR WITHOUT HIM AND WITH HIM THEY
LOOK LIKE PLAYING GOLF WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR SOMETHING.
CHARLIE: IT'S REMARKABLE THE
VAST DISCONNEC